[Music]
let's go
to harrisburg pennsylvania and talk to
samantha what's up samantha
hi dr john how are you speak with you
i'm good how are you remarkable we are
rocking on to the break-a-dawn what's up
okay so um
i am currently separated from my husband
for about three years
we have two children together and i
recently found out that he got a dui
um
so i'm just wondering
how
or if i should talk to the kids about
this
boundaries i should set how old are the
kids
15 and 12. well almost 16 she's turning
16 next month
so my first question is why in the world
are y'all separated but not divorced
well the one thing that's keeping us
married right now is insurance i carry
the health insurance and
um
just trying to
you know
give that to him for now um instead of
adding an extra expense why did you all
get something
mainly because of his drinking
can i tell you some real hard truths is
that okay
yes okay and i know that you know what
i'm about to say
okay
you're trying to keep a fantasy alive
and you have to let it go
okay you love this guy
possibly more than he loves himself
and he's also dangerous and he has hurt
you correct
yes okay
you made a choice for your safety to
leave
whether that's physical safety emotional
safety psychological whatever you made a
choice to go
but what you're doing is you're you're
suffocating everybody
and you're not letting people go
and so the idea that
did you leave him
yes do you have some deep guilt over
that
um
i do
because
i kept the house
and he he moved out
um so i kind of have i have guilt with
that and
you know he still
you know says i'm the one that you know
that
did this and
made this choice and you know so i do
i do carry that it feels like you were
trying to pacify or
ban it over your guilt by saying but at
least i give him health insurance
i've i've kicked him out he's created
his own life
but at least i still provided health
insurance
yeah pretty much and sam i'm never gonna
you've heard me say this um
if you're an abusive situation i would
tell you something told you you have to
leave you got to get out of there
and you left but only part way and if
you're going to be gone after three
years you got to go
your kids are
bearing the brunt of this
okay and i know that's hard to say and
it's hard to hear i'm a dad too that's
the worst thing i could possibly hear
but your kids are continuing this
fantasy
that mom and dad are still married
they're just lived separately and still
and your husband's drinking is clearly
still not in control and now he's
putting your kids lives at risk because
they get to go see him is that right
well
they only really see him about once a
week for a few hours
okay that will begin to change as they
get older
unless there's some sort of
okay let me just cut to it did he ever
hurt you
no so why'd you leave
did he cheat on you
no
um i just couldn't take the drinking
anymore and he was getting
um
a little verbally abusive calling me
names just being mean
towards me
um and i just you know we were fighting
all the time and i didn't want i didn't
want the kids to continue to live in
that situation right
and and i i think that's a wise choice
i'm not for one second going to say that
wasn't a good choice
um do you have desires to be married to
him
no i have
i am
grieving the loss of what i thought my
life would be there you go
but i
him
being the person who he is right now i i
do not wish to be with him no okay the
way you just said that suggests but
maybe one day he'll not be that person
that he is and then it will all work out
and you're trying to you're trying to
have a foot in both worlds and you can't
do that
because you're you're asking this 15
year old and this 12 year old to have
feats in both world 2 and they can't do
that
you can you can't do that and i'll tell
you even you're making yourself insane
you know that you are right
a little yeah you're running two
households and you're parenting him too
oh i can just go on i don't want to beat
you up i'm just telling you you've got
to make a decision
i'm going to be married with this guy
and we're going to go to therapy i'm
going to try to figure this out and he's
going to decide to stop drinking and
stop being unsafe
and
i think that ship has failed okay then
you've got to move on with your life
yeah for your sake for his sake you're
dragging him through this he still
thinks there's a chance this comes back
together
if he got completely sober today
went stone sober went to aaa every day
for 30 days got clean came back to you
would you have him back
um
i don't know that's a good question
um
maybe
don't know i think there's uh there's a
lot of hurt and resentment
um with both of us so i'm not sure if if
that would even be enough at this point
somehow you've drawn a line in your
house between kicking him out and
getting divorced where does that line
come from because it's been three years
i know
um you have an imaginary line between
that this is this is not great but it's
okay but if i cross this line i'm done
for
and i would tell here's what i tell you
you've crossed that line you're way past
that line
yeah
and so
what you've done now is put yourself in
an unsafe position because you were
still illegally bound to this person
yeah kids are still legally bound to
this person who is demonstrating again
with what third dui he's unsafe
yeah
and he clearly needs help and support
and i love the guy
that's i i think the greatest gift you
could give him is to cut him lose
yeah you're right and i would say this
for 30 days if you're having a 30-day
separation i think those are important
sometimes or a sick we've been in part
for six months and we're still going to
therapy this isn't that this is you've
been divorced for three years you've
just never gone through the process
right
right yeah
and here's another thing if you called
me and said hey this happened three
years and then my husband's been clean
for four months
and i still love him i would say go all
in i'd be all for that obviously do it
safely and all that but it doesn't sound
like it's gonna happen
yeah no
no he doesn't think he has a problem
okay
and so
we that that exceeds the scope of this
call what i would tell you is you've got
to at some point start making some plans
okay
if to answer your original question
i would not have if i felt it unsafe
to be with somebody
i would i would feel this especially
that that about my kids
yeah okay
that's the way i would look at that
problem if people get divorced because
such and such cheated on me um i still
think people can be good great parents
there i think you figured that out you
co-parent or we just fight a lot
whatever we just have different values
people get divorced for a million
different reasons
if somebody leaves a home because that
person's unsafe
then i'm gonna go to the map for my kids
too
yeah you know what i mean
yes and i think that's partially why i
do not
um push the issue of him having the
children more
um because i just
i'm not sure if that's the best for them
tell me say that statement again but
tell me truthfully
you said i'm i'm i'm not so sure that
that's the best for them tell me the
truth on that statement
um
[Music]
i'm not sure what you know that it's not
safe for them
yeah
you know that
somebody told you a long time ago that
what you think and feel and believe
doesn't matter and i'm telling you it
does
and living with an alcoholic that's
often you're crazy you're ridiculous
you're not seeing things yeah right
oh yeah
all the time did you grow up with an
alcoholic too
no this is all new
yes okay
well i mean he's had a problem ever
since we were together
okay
um
i just thought he would
grow out of it
you were going to fix him that was so
kind of you
think that way yes
exactly and then it's like oh i know it
will help let's have a baby and it's
like oh i know what happened help two
babies
yes
yes yeah
and here you find yourself i'm
heartbroken for you i'm heartbroken for
him i hope i hope hope hope he gets the
help that he needs he deserves that and
those kids deserve their dad
um
based on what i'm looking at right here
he doesn't sound safe
he doesn't sound safe
um and you've put yourself in a
situation your kid's in a situation and
him in a situation that's untenable
just this this kind of half in half out
fantasy life
i'm not i i can go through my day and
never have to say the words i'm divorced
um i get to say that it's just kind of
it's bordering on disingenuous at this
point
yeah
and that might mean you have to sell the
house and split equity all those all
that ugliness right that's part of legal
separation
but i would suggest that's part of the
decision you made when you decided to
move out three-year-old kick him out
three years ago not that it's a wrong
decision that just that decision comes
with consequence like all decisions
happen right
right and so it's time to get with a
good counselor and a good lawyer and
start having those hard conversations or
to sit down with him and say where are
we what's the status of our relationship
does he still have fantasies about
getting back with you
i i don't think so okay why isn't he
filed on you because health insurance
yeah i mean really the insurance is like
the main thing he has already signed
over the house to me um
really really the only thing yeah it's
just an extra expense that he doesn't
want to have right now what's the equity
accumulated in that home
oh
probably
60 000
oh that's it
yeah okay
okay so he just gave it to you
yeah
so yeah i mean do what you want to do i
i would not um if i was in this
situation and i had been married to
somebody who was struggling with alcohol
abuse and alcohol addiction and they
have a history of duis and they got yet
another one it would be um less about it
do i tell the kids and all that it would
be my kids will not be dad's struggling
dad's not
dead sick he's struggling and um
uh
we're not gonna get in the car with that
eyes apparently i'm not gonna allow that
it's not gonna allow it and if he's
unsafe at home too you're not gonna he
can't be there when he's drinking which
is all the time now so we're just not
going to go over there
yeah the best typically
okay the best way forward there is a
court outlining those
protections
okay because right now he's their dad
and he's still your husband and so there
are still some
at any moment he comes in and says no
those are my kids
and i can have them whenever i want them
and you would say no you can't and he'd
be like
who says who
right
yeah that's where the court really helps
define because the court says i say so
when it comes to child safety
okay all of this breaks my harp sam i'm
sorry
thank you
i know it's the worst do you have
somebody you have somebody with you i
know and this is how you drew it up
right you didn't want to be like this
you didn't want your kids to come from a
divorced family right
absolutely not i know that stinks man
i'm sorry
sorry thank you
yeah
your values and beliefs and feelings
count they matter
they're important
and thank you
yeah good luck with what comes next it's
gonna be hey listen make no mistake it's
gonna be hard the next few steps are
gonna be hard actually gonna be harder
than you think and they're gonna be
easier in some other ways
um
that's tough that's tough that's tough
yeah get over the counselor and get with
an attorney soon and let's dig into
what's next